frankie montas will pitch for the years
today frankie one and one at 2.25 era
making his fourth start two out no one
on for third baseman alex bregman here's
the one-two offering and that's swung
out or miss and a slider away and down
goes bregman and montas
sails throw one two three top of the
first with two strikeouts
doing the pitching for the astros is
lefty from her valdez his record so far
this year is owen one but his era is
2.53
simeon leads off for this bottom of the
first after the astros went down one two
three in the top half
lefty turns kicks here's the fish
demarcus swung on drill down the left
field line if it's fair it's gone and
that baby's gone
marcus simeon with his first home run of
2020
and one nothing is in the first
first of what should be minnie
and that'll bring up pinder
runners will be going
here's the 3-2 defender swing and a miss
got him on a high fast ball and the
inning is over
now josh reddick will try and
pick him up with two out and guerrio
still at second top of the second deep
in the box left-hander hitter the pitch
by frankie is a ground ball to the right
side right defender he has it he throws
the first inning over guri all stranded
at second
sean murphy stands in right-handed
hitting catcher
here's the 1-1
that's grounded to the right side to his
left altuve he was to the
opposite side of second base but able to
get to that and throw out murphy and in
the inning straw one for five last night
here's his 1-2 rolled past the mound to
the right of the second baseman pender
gloves those across the body great
stretch by olson and they get the speedy
straw by a stride career year last year
last season for mark canna oakland
trying to win their eighth consecutive
game
and the 1-1 bounce left side of the hole
tough play by correa backhand and he
throws across his body and throws out
kenna pinder went down on strikes in the
first with two on and two out
here's chad pinder who struck out
his first time up carlos to the backhand
long throw and a strong one one two
three inning for fraumber valdez a
couple of groundouts in a strikeout the
astros have a lead off base runner for
correa
two two
and that's grounded softly left side
charging at the shortstop city in the
second for one on the first by pender
not in time not hit hard enough
to turn two quickly two away and that'll
bring up
sean murphy
2-0 pitch to murphy has driven to center
field straw went in now going back
leaping and he makes the catch he was
fooled
by how hard that ball was hit off the
bat of murphy then racing back with his
great speed and just out run out ran the
ball it got to the warning track and
reached over the shoulder to make the
catch
so here's kyle tucker who struck out and
popped out
two old pitches bunted but it's back
toward the mount backhand montas throws
to first for the out so tucker with the
shift a good idea trying to bun his way
aboard but he angled it closer to the
mount and frankie bouncing off to his
right
toward the third base side and pretty
routine play and so tucker is out
being an athlete
look at montos right here like you said
cool calm collected
here's 96 holy yeah put that in your
pocket here's altuve one nothing is line
driving speared by semi into the
backhand side and that quickly the top
of the six comes to an end
and chapman's one for two as the astros
draw the infield in one nothing is in
the sixth
deep in the box a slightly open stance
to turn the delivery and it's swung on
chopped left side simeon's going on
contact he's gonna score bregman throws
to first for the out and these lead two
nothing and now lefty on left here with
matt olson
now the o1 pitch and it swung on a high
fly ball this is on the infield now in
the short right altuve back toward fair
territory and the ball drops altuve
didn't catch it
and now they have
a canna and a pickle here and ken is
going to get tacked out by bregman oh
that was a huge break for the astros
bring michael brantley to the plate with
the a's up by a pair
so the a's two runs on five hits a swing
by
brantley and he sends one a deep right
center field loriano back again fighting
the sun at the wall reaches out kisses
the padding and makes the catch man oh
man here's guriel
he swings it fist one on the right side
backhanded by olsen in the hole
underhand toss to frankie mutasa four
pitch
one two three seventh inning for frankie
now here's marcus he has scored twice
today
simeon has scored nine times now this
year big pitch for fromber
bottom of the seventh inning here it is
the curve ball got him strike three gets
semi into chase that'll bring up chapman
who has singles struck out and bounced
out
rodriguez ready right right-hander
delivers it's a drive into right center
field back on it redick reddit going
back and that baby's gone
that chapman goes the other way with his
third home run of the year and a little
cushion for the athletics as they now
lead it three
to nothing one out runner with third
and the ninth inning for bregman who's
over three flip 1-1 and that's lined off
the glove of a leaping simeon and then a
left-center field tucker scores alex
bregman an rbi single it is three to one
ease and the astrals will bring the
tying run to the plate in the ninth now
guriel the last hope
bregman at first
two outs three to one a's
liam comes to the belt
here's the fish to gureo swung on ground
ball to second right defender he's got
to throw it at first in time and the
ball game is over and the a's have won
their eighth consecutive game